Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Jake:我们执行任务
Jake: We're on a mission.
Alice:什么任务
Alice: What mission?
Jake:我没有我没有把薇薇叫起来
Jake: I didn't wake Tasha up.
Katrina: 这样切
Katrina: Cut it like this.
Jake:然后露丫也没有叫起来
Jake: And Lucia didn't wake up either.
Jake:所以我们要齐心协力一起把
Jake: So we need to work together to...
Alice:他没醒
Alice: He's not awake.
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:我打电话他也没有接
Jake: I called him, but he didn't answer.
Shure: 不用切那么细
Shure: Don't cut it so fine.
Jake:有可能是没醒
Jake: Maybe he's still asleep.
Lucia: 因为应该不会在外面
Lucia: Because he probably isn't outside.
Jake:有可能是睡对
Jake: Maybe he's sleeping, right.
Lucia: 对但是反正我刚敲了几次门
Lucia: Yeah, but I knocked several times.
Lucia: 但是好像没醒
Lucia: But it seems like he's not awake.
Alice:威威
Alice: Tasha
Jake:凭什么呀哈哈哈
Jake: Why, hahaha
Alice:该戴眼镜了
Alice: Time to put on your glasses.
Lucia: 这就是见证奇迹的时刻
Lucia: This is the moment of witnessing a miracle.
Jake:凭什么呀
Jake: Why?
Alice:你收拾一下起来吧
Alice: Clean up and get up.
Alice:OK了充电宝呢
Alice: Okay, where's the power bank?
Lucia: 可能是某种心灵感应
Lucia: Maybe some kind of telepathy.
Alice:难道
Alice: Could it be...
Jake:厉害太厉害了
Jake: Awesome, so awesome.
Jake:这这个快没电了
Jake: This one is almost out of battery.
Alice:用这个把
Alice: Use this one then.
Jake:不过你也可以用就是
Jake: But you can use it too...
Alice:14好
Alice: 14 is good.
Jake:对你先把它用完吧
Jake: Yeah, just use it up first.
Alice:14好数字14可以用很久
Alice: 14 is good, number 14 can last a long time.
Lucia: 14可以用挺久的
Lucia: 14 can last quite a while.
Lucia: 我现在在外面基本上一直连着
Lucia: I'm outside most of the time and it stays connected.
Lucia: 但是60回来还有41
Lucia: But when I get back at 60, there's still 41.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:其实暂时咱也不用用
Jake: Actually, we don't need to use it now.
Jake:就是可以等一个小时再用
Jake: We can wait an hour and then use it.
Alice:所以任务没了
Alice: So, the mission is off?
Jake:对我们这是最主要的任务
Jake: Yeah, that's our main mission.
Jake:因为我们要跟着他做甜品
Jake: Because we need to follow him to make desserts.
Jake:对没有他我们确实好像干不了什么
Jake: Yeah, without him, we really can't do much.
Lucia: 今天晚上吃什么甜品
Lucia: What dessert are we having tonight?
Jake:不知道啊听
Jake: No idea, listen.
Lucia: 搓手手
Lucia: Rubbing my hands.
Alice:我是不是要解释下我在干嘛
Alice: Should I explain what I'm doing?
Jake:好啊
Jake: Sure.
Alice:为什么要这样呢
Alice: Why should I do this?
Jake:为什么呢为什么呢为什么呢知道吗
Jake: Why, why, why, do you know?
Alice:为什么呢
Alice: Why?
Alice:AI知道吗
Alice:因为哎呀
Alice: Because, oh.
Alice:AI是不是不知道有打底裤这个东西
Alice:卷边了好了我已经解释过了
Alice: They've rolled up, okay, I've explained it now.
Jake:好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Alice:难道
Alice: Could it be...
Lucia: 那我希望AI知道
Lucia: I hope AI knows.
Lucia: 就是人类的腰带大小是不一样的
Lucia: That human belt sizes vary.
Lucia: 而我这个腰带孔不够细
Lucia: And my belt loop isn't tight enough.
Lucia: 所以我的裤子总在往下掉
Lucia: So my pants keep falling down.
Lucia: 我就要不断提它
Lucia: I have to keep pulling them up.
Lucia: AI你听见了吗
Lucia: AI, did you hear me?
Lucia: 学会了吗
Lucia: Did you learn?
Lucia: 你学会了吗
Lucia: Did you learn it?
Jake:学废了吗
Jake: Did you get it?
Jake:学废了
Jake: I got it.
Lucia: 你看我说他很像哎呀
Lucia: See, I told you he's like, oh.
Alice:这上面能上去吗
Alice: Can we go up there?
Jake:上不去
Jake: No, we can't.
Alice:哦顾客止步
Alice: Oh, customers can't go past.
Alice:他怕我们跳下去吗
Alice: Are they afraid we'll jump down?
Alice:你们刚刚真的是正常敲门的声音吗
Alice: Was that really a normal knocking sound?
Lucia: 真的是
Lucia: It really was.
Jake:挺正常的
Jake: Pretty normal.
Alice:可能我没有心灵感应
Alice: Maybe I don't have psychic powers.
Alice:一个啊我的衣服没拿
Alice: Oh no, I forgot my clothes.
Alice:饿了
Alice: I'm hungry.
Lucia: 我们竟然还买了煎牛排好酷啊
Lucia: We even bought steaks to fry, so cool.
Alice:我先吃这个吧
Alice: I'll eat this first.
Shure: 需要腌的都放进来
Shure: Put everything that needs marinating in.
Katrina: 嗯然后呢
Katrina: Okay, then?
Shure: 这些大概两斤多肉
Shure: This is about two pounds of meat.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 然后12个鸡翅
Shure: And 12 chicken wings.
Jake:情
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 一斤不到一斤排骨
Shure: Less than a pound of ribs.
Katrina: 嗯然后呢
Katrina: Hmm, then?
Alice:这是谁的水吗
Alice: Whose water is this?
Katrina: 没有这是外外卖买的是
Katrina: No, it was bought with the takeout.
Jake:没开过哦
Jake: It hasn't been opened.
Shure: 啊我
Shure: Oh, I...
Shure: 我为了配配那什么然后带的
Shure: I brought it to go with the food or something.
Shure: 随便打开
Shure: Just open it.
Shure: 打开就行
Shure: Open it, it's fine.
Jake:我们做什么
Jake: What are we making?
Alice:一个很有品位的水
Alice: A very classy water.
Jake:做什么芒果
Jake: Making what, mango?
Shure: 帮我拍个视频什么的谢谢你
Shure: Help me shoot a video or something, thank you.
Katrina: 要拍到脸吗
Katrina: Do you need to film the face?
Shure: 不用拍了脸拍了手就行
Shure: No need, just film the hands.
Alice:嗦芒果糊
Alice: Mango smoothie.
Lucia: 土豆是今天晚上吃的吧同志们
Lucia: The potatoes are for tonight, right, everyone?
Jake:土豆
Jake: Potatoes.
Shure: 做一做马杀鸡
Shure: Doing some massage.
Alice:是的烤土豆片
Alice: Yes, baked potato slices.
Shure: 这感觉料酒可以再倒一点对
Shure: Feels like we can add a bit more cooking wine, right?
Lucia: 那我就把它拆开了
Lucia: Then I'll just open it.
Jake:拆吧
Jake: Go ahead.
Lucia: 这个可以用来暂时性的放一下
Lucia: This can be used to hold it temporarily.
Alice:酸死了这个
Alice: This is so sour.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Alice:这怎么这么酸 我看看
Alice: Why is this so sour? Let me see.
Alice:你再给他做马杀鸡
Alice: Are you giving it another massage?
Shure: 差不多
Shure: Almost.
Katrina: 说独家秘方
Katrina: Talking about a secret recipe.
Katrina: 敬请期待
Katrina: Stay tuned.
Alice:独家秘方
Alice: Secret recipe.
Alice:咋调的呀
Alice: How do you make it?
Katrina: 他妈祖传的
Katrina: It's passed down from his mom.
Jake:始于秦始皇时期哪一年
Jake: From the time of Emperor Qin Shi Huang, which year exactly?
Katrina: 哈哈哈终于修树
Katrina: Hahaha, finally Shure.
Shure: 不多
Shure: Not much.
Alice:公元前多少年
Alice: How many years before Christ?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:终于救赎
Jake: Finally, redemption.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈他妈的
Shure: Hahaha, damn it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈啊
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 你这话我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you this.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 哈哈哈祖传
Shure: Hahaha, it's a family tradition.
Shure: 然后终于修缮是吧
Shure: And finally it's fixed, right?
Shure: 怎么我这边就意思是无出其右了
Shure: So, from my perspective, it's unparalleled.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Alice:意思是无出其右了
Alice: It means it's unparalleled.
Jake:发扬发扬光大
Jake: Carry it forward, make it bigger.
Alice:知道没有人能超越你了
Alice: You know, no one can surpass you.
Shure: 知道没有人超越
Shure: No one can surpass.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:就是变化巨大
Jake: The change is huge.
Shure: 这变化巨大
Shure: This change is huge.
Jake:这已经不算了
Jake: This doesn't count anymore.
Alice:就后面后来者再没有人能够超过你了
Alice: Then in the future, no one can surpass you.
Jake:独树一帜
Jake: Unique.
Alice:太牛逼了
Alice: It's amazing.
Shure: OK太牛逼了嘎嘎行
Shure: OK, it's amazing, really great.
Katrina: 新的流派
Katrina: A new style.